ceci n'est pas un contrôle routier mais
une sensibilisation à la sécurité
routière des motards un dimanche après
midi consacré aux limitations de vitesse
et au bruit des motos dans la vallée de
chevreuse j'essaie de rester en règle au
maximum en termes de bruit
réglementation les papiers les plaques
etc
je préfère faire du bruit j'aime jamais
être entendu parler les voitures je
trouve ça plus plus sécuritaire mais je
me suis pris une prune 90 euros il ya
deux semaines là du coup j'ai remis ma
she can nous vous encourageons nous les
motards à respecter cette réglementation
parce que la ffmc nous pensons aussi que
la route se partage avec les autres
usagers ainsi qu avec les riverains pour
éviter les nuisances sonores les motards
utilise une chicane un objet obligatoire
installé dans le pot d'échappement en
cas d'absence cette infraction est
sanctionné d'une contravention de 90
euros
des situations fréquentes pour les
gendarmes on a tenté d'identifier la
cause principale effectivement c'est
l'absence de chicanes une pièce
métallique qui est dans le pot et de
l'échappement et qu'ils retiraient pour
gagner en puissance ou juste pour se
faire plaisir aux niveaux au niveau
bruit donc effectivement au niveau
sonore est important les routes de la
vie tchô ressentent à tout le monde à
condition de respecter tous les
utilisateurs notamment en matière de
bruit vous l'entendez vous le voyez ça
fait beaucoup de bruit et donc il faut
respecter les règles du code de la route
et notamment le respect des silencieux
sur les pots d'échappement le député
jean noël barrot porte plusieurs
amendements pour notamment renforcer les
sanctions sur les nuisances sonores
le texte est présenté en séance publique
le 7 juin prochain à l'assemblée
nationale